[Music]
it's harvest time for little grower Ron
Longbottom at his grass patch property
near esperance we've been harvesting
fees for quite a long time say lentils
for us is quite similar grower interest
in lentils is on the increase their
popularity is well-established in
eastern Australia in w.a
the industry small but developing
especially in the esperan sport zone the
interest is prompting research with GRDC
support into lentil agronomy growth
harvesting practices and good returns
being another incentive we've got the
soils and the farmers with experience
with peas and then lentils are usually
slightly higher priced so that's sort of
driving the change to lentils GRDC
projects include investment in measuring
and monitoring ways to improve the
agronomy of lentils and highlighting
some of the new and promising varieties
that don't shatter shed or lodge high
lands just come out I reckon it's gonna
be a winner and hallmark I think is
proved very good round locally most of
our lentils are bolt but the hallmark in
highland seemed to have some of their
characteristics plus more herbicide
options the new variety certainly have a
bit more vigor about them and the other
thing we do is were sowing them early so
one of the things that actually ron was
a sort of an innovator was saying the
lentils in the middle of April and I
just jump out of the ground and grow
better
one of the critical things with growing
lentils and peas is setting your paddock
up properly to start with in years gone
by we've tracked changed paddocks to
clean up a lot of the stumps and then
rolling it straight behind the cedar
which most people that grow please do
and you do the same with lentils modern
harvester fronts are removing barriers
to make harvesting lentils easier
including Otto on ground pressure
monitoring yes you see here on the
screen this head is in float mode so the
header is picking up off a sensor down
here you'll see the one with the numbers
on it I've sort of told it around about
the one and a half to maintain that
amount of pressure on the ground so as
we're going along the computer in the
header is automatically monitoring him
as precious through that potentiometer I
don't really need to hang on to the
hydrostatic part from the fact that if I
see a stump that is made probably one of
the biggest differences to harvesting
legumes I think
[Music]
Harvester setup does require added
contingencies to avoid cracking the
lentils in hotter weather sort of got
you concave quite open you've slowed
your rotor down similar fan speed to if
you are harvesting wheat because lentils
are quite heavy
you can have your sips at a similar
setting to wheat taking steps to
minimise fire risk is important because
lentil residue has a low ignition point
ron has installed thermal blankets to
reduce risk this is the muffler and the
exhaust so they wrap around and then
they continue down here at the turbo the
manifold and the turbo themselves are
the hottest parts that's one of the sort
of the engine modifications we've done
you know to sort of help with reducing
fires apart from some on-farm storage
mark Seymour says upfront investment to
launch inter lentils doesn't need to be
overly significant well lentils easy to
store you don't have to have a sealed sy
like bond and carrier put this big shed
up it can hold 2,000 tonnes of lentils
they tarp them up and they're good for
six or seven months Mark's advice is to
give lentils ago they offer an option of
another break crop in the rotation and
grdc's project priorities are all aimed
at achieving increased yields and grower
returns I think it's not as hard as it
can sound certainly the harvesting puts
people off but as you've heard from Ron
and other people that the harvesting
with new headers is quite different to
ten or fifteen years ago
so if don't be scared
[Music]
go to the description bar below for the
latest information links and resources